very important to fully accept someone
as they are but if you don't then you
can't you can't really accurately relate
to them or even determine that's it for
me I didn't know bullies you can you
can't tell them whether or not we like
come on really unless you couldn't
accept them for who they are doesn't
mean so when you sex someone who they
are doesn't necessarily mean you put up
a few there but denying you know not
accepting someone for who they are in a
certain way you know but I'm playing
with words a little bit trying to sort
of create two different things rather
something that is sometimes one so when
accepting someone had the hardest time
being okay as that person as they are in
relationship to you and not leaving them
or something I've added them in there
but we can make it more refined but you
say if we can accepts honor as they are
being willing in in other words to see
them and then accepting that that's how
they are and then making this
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I mean I think that you said that
while we can't date potential all right
you can't date potential well I mean you
of course always want more I mean and
deeper and all of that that's a
different story but fundamentally you
have to be okay with who somebody is
that doesn't mean you have to be with
everything they do like for instance I
don't know you're dating a woman you
really like her you like who she is in
general you know with a few I mean
nobody's perfect but you you know she
let's say she works for a bank you know
and she wants to progress in the bank
but somehow you think money is evil and
she shouldn't be working for a bank or
so well that's an actual issue because
unless this is some casual job for her
that she could do this one or that one
but if she's a career you don't like
that's an actual issue right but like
for instance if she I don't know doesn't
wash her hair often enough because she's
not aware of the fact that her scalp
smells after three days did you'd be
surprised what people get you know or or
or she eats in a way that you don't like
or something those are things you can
address
who are her sake right not for your sake
but for her sake because you know the
only one who's smelling the scalp or
listening to her each with an open mouth
right you go to a restaurant everybody
else is kind of like alright lady where
were you raised right so those are
things those are things that can be
addressed where you can go I don't know
if you're aware of the fact that you
open your mouth when you're eating and
your food spills out while you're
talking to people while you're eating
right if she goes yeah I'm fully aware
of that and that's who I am
well then you have to deal with can you
stomach it or not but if it's just a
matter of a bit of refinement here or
there that's perfectly okay and
supporting somebody in going for the
drop that they want to is perfectly okay
but you know things like looks career
things around children religion
political ideology you don't want to
[ __ ] with that but you have to assume
that because somebody wants to change
does not necessarily mean they will
change as we all know right because how
long does it take you to change a habit
alright so if it takes her as long as it
takes you to change a habit that might
be a long time and can you live with her
the way she is now till she's changed
right if she of course everybody changes
in relationship particularly if you
engage in long term relationships it's a
it's a very you know it's startling you
know how it much people change and it's
always a matter of are you changing in
in ways that are agreeable which might
be or sometimes it becomes not agreeable
and then you have what they call so
lovely in divorce court irreconcilable
differences